the September box office got a nice shot
in the arm thanks to the newest
adaptation of Stephen King's it
meanwhile movie fans also got some
exciting new previews for what's to come
in the near future
from exciting thrillers to clever
comedies here are the most promising
trailers of the month of September the
Snowman the Snowman already had one
riveting preview but the International
trailer offers even more exciting
glimpses at the mystery thriller the
film follows Harry hull a man tasked
with hunting down the elusive snowman
killer who leaves the childhood
playthings as a way to mark his victims
and to thanks to this new autumn look at
the wintery movie it's clear that the
killer is playing some serious mind
games with everyone including reporting
his next victim as missing before he
actually abducts her just to make things
even more grisly this diabolical move
proves a snowman killer is even more
twisted than ordinary serial killers
winter is about to come terrifying the
early on October 20th when this movie
lands in theatres tragedy girls social
media obsession gets taken to a deadly
new level and the trailer for the comedy
thriller tragedy girls the movie
features two teens who decide to become
crime reporters in an effort to boost as
social media influence however they
quickly decide that the best way to stay
on top of the news is to creator
themselves you know what comes next the
pair murder their classmates kicking off
with a big-time social-media influencer
the girls take well to their newfound
fame and they get even more and more
invested in their killings and the likes
that come along with them count on this
one to make you rethink your digital
game starting October 20th a bad mom's
Christmas this secrets are bad mom's
will bring back our trio of mothers as
they take back the holidays from the
world's toughest Peck tations the one
problem the loss of after contend with
their own mothers who have dropped in to
spread some holiday jeers who are on mom
mom's don't enjoy thank you enjoy the
trailer is full of dirty hijinks
including a Santa Claus stripper so
prepare for some naughty list style fun
this season a bad mom's Christmas London
theaters November 3rd Thelma the
Norwegian supernatural thriller Thelma
centers on a new college student who
comes to discover she has supernatural
powers she can't explain that might seem
like a nice alternative to gaining the
freshman 15 but from the looks of this
trailer of those
will become terrifying rather than
thrilling this arthouse horror flick
will hit theaters on November 10th just
in time for a distraction from finals
Cook Off a movie many many years in the
making
Melissa McCarthy's Cook Off was filmed
way way back in 2006 before the actress
broke out of her Academy award-nominated
performance and bridesmaids with
McCarthy's huge star power the shelved
film was brought back from the dead and
reportedly reacted featuring McCarthy is
one of the many competitors in a cooking
competition at the local hotel the film
promises lots of lunacy and delicious
treats when it finally hits theaters on
November 17th all the money in the world
Ridley Scott investigates one of the
world's most famous kidnappings and the
first trailer for his upcoming action
drama all the money in the world the
movie follows the 1973 abduction of john
paul Getty the third the grandson of the
richest man in the world the movie
focuses on the desperate actions that
his mother Gayle had to undergo in order
to get him back when her billionaire
father and Loras am willing to cough up
the cash to get his grandson back the
real-life drama here is right for the
pickings and it's exciting to see what
Scott and his all-star cast will do with
the story when it lands in theaters
December 8th the shape of water the
first trailer for Guillermo del Toro's
the shape of water was exciting enough
but this new red band the preview is
even more incredible this new glimpse of
the otherworldly fairy tale shows just
how feisty Eliza will be more protecting
the creature she loves although she
seemed too stoic and innocent in the
first glimpse we saw off the movie this
new trailer proves Eliza isn't afraid to
get her hands dirty on behalf of her
Blue Lagoon style power considering
critics are already hailing this film
it's clear the shape of water will be a
must-see on its December 8th release the
disaster artist the first trailer for
the disaster artist to focus on just one
familiar moment from the room but this
new teaser about the making of the worst
movie in the world a further explores
the relationship between Tommy Wiseau
and his co-star Greg Sestero
played by real-life brothers James and
Dave Franco
counts on this movie to be a lot better
than the one it's chronicling when the
disaster artist breaks into theaters on
December 1st wide release on December
8th Jumanji
welcome to the jungle the new trailer
for Jumanji welcome to the jungle proves
that sometimes the sequels might not be
such a terrible idea this new look at
the film shows that none of the
characters in the new game will take to
their avatar characters very well in the
new virtual world with some
laugh-out-loud moments and a cleverly
imagination of the original Jumanji it
might just be worth it to roll the dice
and welcome to the jungle when it
arrives on screen December 20th I hate
this game everybody else got good stuff
weakness Hey yes cake is my weakness
downsizing Matt Damon might be a huge
star but he's hitting the small time for
the upcoming comedy downsizing the film
features him as a man who alongside his
wife decides to commit a new procedure
that shrinks people down until they're 5
inches tall wow that is wild isn't it
it's just wild
consider it a modern satirical take on
Honey I Shrunk the Kids look for
downsizing to hit the big screen on
December 22nd red Sparrow Jennifer
Lawrence becomes a Russian femme fatale
and the upcoming action thriller red
Sparrow she plays a ballerina who after
suffering a career-ending injury turns
to espionage for a Russian intelligence
agency and uses seduction violence and
whatever other means will be necessary
to complete her missions that is until
she meets an American CIA operative who
might test a loyalty to the Kremlin
considering today's political atmosphere
this movie will probably be pretty
timely when it boughs into theaters on
March 2nd team Raider Lara Croft as a
new mission in the first trailer for
alicia vikander's upcoming Tomb Raider
reboots the film features the Oscar
winner as the adventurer as she sets off
to find out what happened to her father
who died while searching for a tomb
located on a mythical Japanese island
the trailer hints that the film will
draw heavily from the tenth installment
on the game franchise which offered up a
more complex take on the character than
the releases that inspire the Angelina
Jolie led movies look for Lara Croft to
raid the box office when the new movie
lands and theaters are March 16th
hostiles
Christian Bale takes a trip back in time
for the upcoming drama hostile
which features him as an army captain
tasked with bringing a sick cheyenne war
chief and his family back to their
tribal lands at 1892 from the looks of
this preview may or may be putting
forward another award-winning
performance in this period drama so keep
your calendar open for when a release
date is announced to fullest historic
film the lodges the haunted house genre
gets a gothic twist in the trailer for
the upcoming horror flick the lodges the
movie features two orphaned twins who
are forced to live in their parents
creepy former home by a secret curse
when a young man who's in love with the
sister tries to free the pair his
actions set off a deadly and terrifying
reaction with chilling visuals and
mysteries aplenty
this one is sure to draw out some scares
when it's released thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]